I'm Patrick Brady from the Android auto
team and I'm here with Loren rossik and
Dean to give you an update on Android
and cars we got a lot to cover today and
a lot of automotive puns so let's buckle
up and get driving we're incredibly
excited about the automotive space right
now because we see it going through huge
transformations from electrification to
connectivity sensors in input devices
sharing an autonomy cars are rapidly
turning into full-blown computers on
wheels with high-speed mobile
connections microphones cameras and
screens everywhere of all shapes and
sizes
it's a computing transformation unlike
many we've seen before and it opens up
new opportunities for innovation and for
developers Android auto is an effort
from Google and our partners to bring
these advances together and create a
safe and seamless connected experience
for drivers everywhere of course that's
a lot easier said than done
there are dozens of different car
platforms today many different input
types from touchscreens to touch pads
and rotary controllers many different
screen shapes and sizes and resolutions
layer on top of that the myriad driver
distraction guidelines and regulations
across the globe if every software
developer had to deal with this level of
complexity we would never be able to
realize the potential that automotive
holes well at Google we believe that
platforms can reduce that complexity and
allow developers to just focus on
innovation we saw that happen on the web
and in mobile and we're working hard to
do the same thing here making Android
the platform for the car today you can
see that vision at work in any Android
auto compatible car drivers have access
to their favorite apps right from the
cars display and developers build their
app once for every car without having to
worry
the make and model the screen size the
input type we started this journey back
in 2014 partnering with leading car
brands to bring Android out in their
cars
we've made a lot of progress since then
and I'd like to give you just a quick
update on how things are going we
continue to see incredible growth in
compatible cars and aftermarket systems
with over 500 models available today
from 50 different brands since last i/o
we've seen first launches from Fiat Alfa
Romeo Tata Motors and smart in 2018
bringing exciting new launches from
Jaguar Land Rover Mazda and many more
just last month
JVC and Kenwood launched the first head
units supporting Android auto Wireless
we're really excited about Wireless and
we look forward to more partner launches
in the months ahead with these great
partnerships were well on our way to
making an Troisi platform the developer
platform for every new car shipped but
what about the 1 billion cars on the
road that predated Android auto what do
we do for those cars well of course we
know not everyone has a compatible
vehicle so we made the Android Auto app
available to all Android users as a
standalone experience and this opens up
the platform and the ecosystem to many
millions of drivers no matter what kind
of car they drive as we've made Android
auto available to more cars and more
drivers we're happy to say that the
strong user growth continues here's
where we were in IO 2016 IO 2017 and
today at i/o 2018 we've seen over 300%
user growth in the last year alone in
fact as you can see in the chart our
growth is accelerating as we make
Android auto available to more cars and
more drivers and that consistent
platform and large install base is a
great opportunity for developers so we
continue to see strong growth on that
front as well in the last year we've
seen popular apps like Waze Google Play
Books
text me Sirius XM and Plex launch in
Android auto Google Play now has
thousands of Android auto apps available
and that's a 200% growth from last year
in January we also launched the Google
assistant in Android auto opening up a
new way for drivers to say safely
connected in the car and for developers
to build car friendly experiences and
the great thing is actions built for the
Google assistant work across the
assistant surfaces from smart speakers
to TVs wearables and mobile we're
excited about some of the early
favorites in automotive such as spot
hero which helps you find and reserve
parking spots busu bringing personalized
language learning right into your car
and CNBC bringing you the most
up-to-date business news and market
insights on-the-go the actions on Google
ecosystem is exploding we're super
excited to see what you all build next
but of course that's just the beginning
for Android in cars as cars advance we
have the opportunity to create an even
more seamless experience by building
Android right into the car itself and
that's why we started an effort back in
2016 to build automotive support right
into the platform the first demo of that
work was right here at i/o in 2016 with
this concept Maserati with a lot of help
from the industry we're investing in
building automotive features into each
Android release making Android a turnkey
platform for infotainment just as it's
been a turnkey solution for phones and
the rest of the industry is taking
notice last year two of the world's most
innovative car makers outtie and Volvo
announced that Android will power their
future in car experiences if you had a
chance to see the in-car demos last year
we think you'll understand our
excitement for the future and why we
look forward to many more car makers
following in their tracks
earlier this week Volvo and Google
announced a partnership to bring Google
services to the next generation Android
powered Volvo cars with the Google
assistant Google Maps and the Play Store
seamlessly integrated into the census
system we're creating a new benchmark
for the connected driving experience and
a great opportunity for all of you our
developers and of course this all works
no matter what kind of phone the driver
has or even if they leave their phone at
home to get a preview of that experience
today swing by the Android auto sandbox
where you can see it in live and in
action in an XC 40 so we've made a lot
of progress since Android auto first hit
the road and we're well on our way to
establishing Android as the platform for
automotive in old cars new cars and the
next generation of cars coming up the
road ahead but of course it's not enough
to just make Android available
everywhere we're also working hard to
make sure it's the best possible
experience for users and our developers
we've listened to them a lot over the
last year talking with great developers
like Spotify and others to hear what
they want to see from Android auto next
today I'd like to give you a sneak peek
of some of the exciting changes we're
making and what it means for the
developer community so now I'd like to
invite up Lauren to tell us where
Android is going next
[Applause]
good morning and hello everyone my name
is Lauren I'm going to be speaking about
some of the new challenges we are facing
on the auto space and how we're
addressing them we've spoken before
about why we were building to Android
auto and at the core of our experience
is our overarching commitment to
bringing this safe and connected
experience to every vehicle this is
particularly important as the primary
responsibility of the driver is to drive
everything else we do is secondary to
really highlight this we showed a photo
of a driver playing Pokemon go during
one of our research sessions don't worry
everyone is safe
we were parked with this extreme example
struggle showcases the struggle we face
while balancing the tension we feel
between balancing our digital and our
physical lives by developing strategies
to manage attention we can provide a
safer in car experience to keep drivers
connected and as you heard from Patrick
screens are getting bigger
haider taller more shapes and more
inputs such as touchpad we are starting
to think about how to evolve our UI to
better scale and adapt for the future
the best part is as developers you don't
have to worry about these layout changes
display size variants or even supporting
these input mechanisms because the
Android auto platform takes on these
challenges for you furthermore we're
looking to see where Android auto is
going next as part of our commitment to
developing the best possible in vehicle
experience we're developing a built-in
experience that feels more at home in
the cockpit so I'd like to introduce our
new Google in-car concept from designs
point of view the goal of this concept
is to adapt Android autos design to a
vehicle specific theme Sissons includes
additional economic details and non so
the vehicles interior design
we can the leverage these vehicle
concepts to prove out new features and
designs working with our partners to
bring them to life besides abstracting
Hardware complexity we're also thinking
about how to enhance our core
experiences and introduce new ways to
promote your content today we will be
highlighting some of the updates to
messaging and media experiences but be
sure to stay tuned as we roll out all of
these updates this year for a live demo
of these vehicles including a preview of
this on-screen experience
stop over to the Android auto sandbox as
part of helping drivers stay connected
with user interfaces that are safer and
more predictable we have developed
multiple ways for you to integrate with
Android auto depending on the nature of
your service for navigation apps we work
directly with developers to ensure they
follow our strict distraction guidelines
and you can also integrate with a Google
assistant which is voice centric and
ideal for in-car use be sure to check
out their sessions this year at i/o
messaging and media make up the largest
number of apps and today we'll be
speaking about the updates we've made to
both of those experiences so let's dive
in beginning with messaging updates
communication apps like whatsapp
telegram and messages integrate with a
messaging template and are displayed via
notifications notifications require less
effort and are highly visible throughout
the experience we've improved the
notification layer this year
including more and unified actions more
unified actions across the surfaces help
drivers react to incoming content
without ever leaving their current
experience and group messaging a feature
developers and drivers have been asking
for now you can stay connected with
multiple people at the same time media
apps like Spotify Pandora pocket casts
and I Heart Radio integrate with the
media template the template is designed
to remove these complexities such as
input screen sizes and orientations and
they're also designed with the
industry's best practices promoting
predictability for drivers across all of
our systems including the phone screen
car display and built-in experiences we
are thrilled to showcase some of the
biggest redesigns we've made to the
media experience since launching Android
auto by focusing on these three key
areas Media template we have
personalized and modern content for an
experience for all of our drivers new
architecture more flexible UI components
and new search capabilities make up the
majority of our updates so let's dive in
new architecture before when drivers got
going they'd have to navigate to the
media section open the drawer and find
that very special commute playlist now
when a driver gets going they no longer
have to seek out the content they wish
to play but the content is brought
forward in a very visual way we've
reached architectured the media
template in order to pull the content
out of the drawer drivers can easily see
content saving additional tabs and
getting there on the road just faster
our new foundation has created many more
opportunities for you to showcase
content for which ways introduced more
components to promote a new flexibility
and ability to express your content in a
more familiar way that is native to the
app now you can create more customized
layouts with list views and subheadings
as well as grid views with really large
graphics additional richer metadata
hints such as explicit content tags
downloaded tags and new and impress tags
with the added benefit of the template
approach each of these new additions are
available regardless of theme from the
Android on the phone or on screen up as
well as customized by the yo-yo your
branding and layouts will be respected
see firsthand how we're doing this with
a Google and car concept at the odds
Road sandbox
our last winter update showcase is a new
search and pivot functionality search is
still hands-free and when a driver asks
for a specific song or artist it just
begins playing in addition to playing
the best match song or artists
automatically drivers can now pivot into
the app for app provided content and
related suggestions with a new search
functionality with further optimize the
search results to include a more
digestible format things like
subheadings and subgroups help drivers
find the content they're looking for
even faster so that's what we've been
working on to enable a healthy in-car
ecosystem i've showcased the new
messaging updates and media updates by
focusing on a new structure new
components and more search capabilities
so I'd like to turn it over to rossik to
teach you how to get started with these
new updates thanks
[Applause]
thanks Lauren hi I'm Rasik and I'm here
to talk to you about what developers
need to do to support our new messaging
and media app features today I'll go
through some code examples that will let
messaging apps you support group
notifications and messing messaging
style also go for our media architecture
and show you how to provide those in-app
search results that Lauren just
mentioned and then finally I'll look at
code changes for media apps to enable
our content browsing visuals let's start
with an example so I live in Seattle and
one of the best things to do on the
weekend
grab the group of friends and head out
to the hills for some hit the slopes
let's use that as our example today
luckily all of us are using Android auto
in the car and we can start - we can
interact with it by voice keeping our
hands on the wheel and our eyes on the
road but we need to coordinate things
like breakfast gas and just our original
progress when Android auto started
supported messaging there wasn't a
standard way to do messaging
notifications on Android we introduced
car extender helper class for one-on-one
conversations but Android notifications
have come a long way since then
messaging style is a newer standard
helper class for generating large format
notifications that include multiple
back-and-forth messages of varying types
between any number of people you should
already be using it to ride rich
notifications on mobile devices today
and enabling Android auto support is a
few short changes away from that so
let's take a look at some code so here's
Steffen asking which run are we going to
hit first alright we set that up in our
messaging style as the message we set
our conversation title ski trip and
since it's a group conversation we set
that to be true next we set up our reply
action we use a semantic action which is
new to messaging style this allows
Android auto and the Google
to know what they should be sending to
the pending intent after the Google
assistant has recognized your voice and
composed a reply it can launch the
messaging app to send that reply next
we'll create a Markus read action you
can imagine a scenario where I'm in the
car and I listen to my message but I
don't really I'm not really ready to
reply yet
this gives the messaging app a callback
to say oh the user read this market is
read and let other participants in the
conversation know finally we bring all
that together in a standard way
with Android notifications we add a
reply action our messaging style and our
mark is read action and the mark is read
action won't show up in the standard
Android UI and we can see the final
result our conversation title is set up
the group the group messaging icons are
all set up from the notification and
then assistant and Android Auto know
that you can reply by voice and even if
you just listen to the message we can
tell that other participants in the
conversation that they've seen it so now
that we've coordinated with everyone we
figured out where we're going we want to
listen to something on the way out to
the mountains alright media in the car
is one of the core user experiences and
getting driver's access to their content
should be front and center now for media
apps to integrate with Android auto they
have to implement two services the Media
Browser service provides a tree of
playable and browsable items the
browsable items are basically folders to
help apps organize their content so
they're not returning a giant list of
songs or podcasts once a user has picked
something playable from the Browse tree
the media session service which the app
implements is used to start music and to
provide metadata and controls for what's
currently playing you can see in this
example the app supports play pause skip
to next get previous and there's also
mechanism for setting up custom actions
things like a 30-second skip
once that media app has implemented
these two services the Google assistant
just works out of the box you say hey
Google Play by ski jams right the Google
assistant will recognize your voice
issue the query and music starts playing
right away what we're introducing today
for in-app searching is the ability to
implement a second extra function on the
Media Browser service to get those
in-app results Media Browser service on
search in this case the APIs surfaced my
ski jams from 2018 as well as my
playlists from my skiing trip last year
awesome now let's look at the code to
make this happen
so for apps which already support
Android auto this is actually really
familiar you have a function which
issues which is issued the query an
extras bundle and a destination for the
result let's break it down
first off apps should just return an
empty list if they can't support the
query okay if things like an empty query
just return an empty list
normally queries actually require a
network call or a database fetch and so
if that's the case and you want to do
work on an extra on a different thread
detach the results do the work on that
other thread and then when you're ready
send the results back to Android auto I
want to mention that these code snippets
actually come from the universal music
player an open source media app
published by Google on github you can
easily cloned compiled and it's a great
reference for using for creating a media
app across Android auto and other
surfaces so now we've got our search
results or a straight skater of 2018
2017 and ski jams notice it returned to
playlists as well as some albums be
really nice of Android auto could group
those we have a way to do that though
in this function we're creating media
items for sending back to Android auto
and it's very easy to annotate a media
item with a group heading Android auto
will look at successive media items and
if they're in the same category will
group them together so if we annotate
our ski jams with playlists and our
albums without albums add our auto
group's them and shows that for you
regardless of screen size and surface
we're also adding a couple more
annotations as Lauren mentioned here I'm
showing explicit annotation it's great
I'm in the car I got my family I don't
want that explicit song to come up also
we're adding a support for downloaded
that way I'm in the mountains I don't
have good cell coverage or I don't want
to burn my data plan on music I have a
chance to pick the right playlist
Android auto shows them right with the
content looks like ski trip 2018 is the
right playlist for my trip there's one
more function that needs updating to
take advantage of these new features
when the Media Browser service starts it
provides Android auto with a media route
and extras in order for search and
bringing content out a drawer to be
enabled you'll need to add a couple of
extras to let Android auto know that you
support these features now lauren
introduced the concept of bringing
content out and being able to show
things as grids or lists and by default
Android auto will show browsable items
the folders as lists because they
generally have an icon and they'll show
content or like playable items as grids
because they're usually much richer and
have a much more detailed artwork but
there are times when it's better to
switch that around so for instance let's
say you have a podcast app in that case
the podcasts which are browsable items
have a much richer artwork right but all
the episodes would share the same
artwork you want to see more about their
detail in a list format we're giving you
the ability to choose that by adding an
extra in your hand
the extra hint in your on route so that
you can switch the order around and
choose grids or lists depending on the
content in your media app so to sum up
some up I've shown code samples for
messaging style Media Browser service on
search specifying additional item
metadata adding content browsing and
searching I'm excited to see developers
access these features in the future and
look for our documentation later this
summer now please welcome Dean up to
talk about tools for Android auto
development
[Applause]
thanks for our sec hi everyone so as
Rasik mentioned i'm here to talk to you
about the tools we provide for
developing and testing your media and
messaging apps and also to give you some
hints and tips to help you make the most
of the platform the first thing I want
to talk about is the desktop head unit
this tool is ideal for testing both your
messaging and media apps as it will
render your apps exactly the same as
you'd see them in production and just as
importantly it allows you to interact
with the assistant just like in a real
car you get the desktop head unit as
part of the Android SDK just select it
from the download manager the
instructions for running the desktop
head unit are on the developer side but
it's fairly easy just start the head
unit server from Android autos developer
menu on the phone you get that by going
to about then tapping ten times on the
about Android auto header to enable
developer mode then choose start head
unit server from the overflow menu that
you can see here plug your phone into
USB port on the computer and launch the
desktop head unit from there you can see
how Android auto will respond to your
apps notifications and also how your
media app will appear in an actual car
but if you're developing a media app I
encourage you to check out the Android
media controller which is an open source
app that we have hosted on github it
will connect to your apps media session
and Media Browser service and shows you
the information your app is presenting
to Android auto in a nice semantic
format if your whitelisting to block
apps other than Android auto from
accessing your browse tree it would
probably be a good idea to either add
the media control to the whitelist
or disable the whitelist while testing
Rasik also briefly touched on the
universal media player but I wanted to
reiterate that we have this great
comprehensive sample media app available
on github but also it gives you a
canonical implementation of a media app
not only on Android auto but also on all
our other services such as where and TV
let's get into some code now the first
bit of code I wanted to talk about was
the standard actions that your app
returns as part of the playback state
you should try to make sure your app
supports the standard actions defined in
playback State Compact such as action
skip to next and action rewind
by using the standard actions you not
only have a great integration with
or oh but you also get assistant
integration with those actions for free
actions like okay good we'll skip tracks
and as we bring Android order to more
surfaces it may not be the case that
those custom actions appear in the same
place they do today
but you can be sure the standard actions
are kept in a place where it makes the
most sense you can use the media
controller app to see what standard
actions you've implemented and also to
see what's available you can see here
that we have an app that does not
implement a standard forwards backwards
action but is instead chosen to
implement those actions as custom
actions now if you were to look at this
app in the desktop head unit you might
not necessarily know that there's
anything wrong because of the way we
rendered the custom actions everything
looks okay but by implementing those
actions as standard actions like this we
can leave the custom actions for truly
custom functionality
we've done a lot of research with users
and found that users do not want to have
to browse while driving here are a few
quotes from some of our research
sessions where users talk about some of
the issues they have with custom search
and browse users typically want to get
in and go without much fuss and this is
a great opportunity for you to provide
some additional value to your users by
giving them easy access to the playlists
they like or to recommend new content
that they may not have known about
otherwise so I would suggest that you
prioritize surfacing things in the
Browse tree with items most relevant to
driving at the top Rasik showed you
earlier some of the things were doing to
bring content out of the drawer and put
it front and center and you'll
definitely want that first page of
content to be the most useful now that's
not to say you can't include all the
users playlists or whatever in the
Browse tree just keep in mind that the
first few items on your homepage should
be the most relevant to the task of
driving a corollary to that would be to
keep your browse tree shallow no more
than two or three levels deep in fact to
make the most of the new design we've
shown you a two-level deep browse tree
is ideal because then your users will be
able to get to their favorite music or
podcasts with a single tap you can use
the on search method that Rasik
described earlier to allow you users to
search for specific things like a
particular song or a particular artist
one of the challenges we have in Android
auto is that it is used on devices with
many different screen sizes and
resolutions your app isn't necessarily
going to know until the moment it's
plugged into a car what the resolution
of the screen it's displayed on is which
means that it's difficult to predict
what resolution your icons need to be to
look right on any particular screen you
can see here this star icon is too low
resolution for this display and it
really looks out of place with the rest
of the icons so packager icons in the
vector graphics format rather than a
bitmap format vector drawables have been
supported natively in Android since API
level 21 which coincidentally is the
version of Android that Android auto
support was introduced so there's no
reason not to use the native vector
format
you can see here an example of the star
icon from before as a vector graphic and
then better how big I make the icon it
still has nice smooth edges as an added
bonus the file size of this icon is
really small especially compared to
having multiple bitmaps at different
resolutions don't forget you can use
Android Studios vector asset tool to
convert your SVG's to the native android
format while we're on the topic of icons
you should prefer using the URI based
methods for passing as your media rather
than the drawable based methods this
example shows our training one of your
built-in resources as a URI
rather than a drawable using your eyes
allows us to case your resources and to
only allocate memory for the items that
we are actually physically displaying if
the user never Scrolls down to the
fourth page there's no need to allocate
memory for the items down there I also
wanted to briefly touch on something
we've seen with ad supported apps
typically the ads will include some call
to action that may not make sense when
running in the car
for instance they might say tap the
screen to learn more or click here or
something along those lines if you're
running inside Android auto I recommend
adjusting your messaging so that it's
not confusing for people not actually
using your main apps UI and lastly the
process of actually getting your app
onto the Play Store once you've added
this metadata snippet to your manifest
and you've uploaded your app to the Play
Store it only to be reviewed against our
driver distraction guidelines this is a
fairly complicated process but the
guidelines for ensuring a smooth review
are documented in the developer Center
at this link
if our reviewers find issues you'll be
notified by email and we'll be able to
resubmit an updated application for
review so I've gone over a few things
we've learned over the years developing
for Android auto we've got a great
resource in the media controller for
testing media apps and don't forget to
check out the universal media player for
our comprehensive example implementation
use the standard actions where it makes
sense and leave custom actions for
things that are actually custom surface
the important actions at the top in
browse a new search for finding specific
content like a particular song or
Giller album keep the Browse tree
shallow no more than two or three levels
deep use vector graphics for icons and
use the URI based methods rather than
sending raw bitmaps and finally be aware
of the surface you're playing on for ads
and now I'd like to hand back over to
Patrick for our wrap-up hey thanks
thanks Dean so today we showed you how
we're working to make Android the
platform for developers in automotive
and how you can develop your apps on
that platform we also showcased a new
design for Android auto and your apps
across surfaces from old cars to new a
new developer api's that enable your
apps to take advantage of these new
designs and features including messaging
style for group messaging and custom
actions Media browse enhancements to
bring your content forward and annotate
it with rich media metadata and media in
apps search to help your users find the
content they're looking for across your
catalogue of course that's just a sneak
preview of all the developer resources
if you'd like more information to help
you update your apps please visit the
end rate auto developer site at
developer.android.com slash Auto and
I'll also encourage you to take a look
at the universal media player and
Android media colder controller examples
that raw second Dean mentioned which are
freely available as open source software
on github and while you're here you can
also stop by the Android team office
hours which are happening again on
Thursday at 2:30 p.m. to chat with the
Android engineers and business
development teams and ask them questions
directly but if you really want to see
these things in action please come and
check out the Android auto sandbox which
is just around the corner where you can
see the new Android auto design and I
promise you it's not as janky it seems
like we were having some AV issues with
the animations earlier but you can see
the new design operating fluidly
new Range Rover Vell are on a beautiful
wide screen showing simultaneous maps
and media on the UI at the same time
it's really we think of fantastic
experience you can also find the Google
in-car concept that Lauren talked about
which is showing kind of the default
experience in Android that we're making
available as open source software and
Android PE and of course the latest in
car experience from our collaboration
with Volvo in the new Android powered
senses Kinect system running the Google
assistant Google Maps in the Google Play
Store last but not least as with every
session at i/o we want to value your
feedback and we want to hear from you so
we can make our sessions better every
year so please grab a browser and swing
by google.com slash IO scheduled to fill
out a short survey when you have time
leave your feedback thanks very much and
have a great aisle
[Music]
you